and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and today we're
gonna talk about stoicism we're gonna
talk about what it means to live a good
life and we're gonna compare some
different philosophies for living and
we're gonna do all that with today's
guests I'm talking to William B Irvine
today bill you're the author of a couple
quite a few books first of all thank you
for joining us I really appreciate it
I'm looking forward to this conversation
well thank you for the invitation it's a
pleasure to be here now you're you're in
my hometown right now
Dayton Ohio what what brought you out to
Dayton a job rights day that a graduate
student in philosophy and this would
have been in the late 70s and early 80s
and any work you could get counted as a
gift from the gods so I was in
Cincinnati for a year on a faculty
member had gone on leave so they needed
someone to fill that post when he came
back I was no longer needed and just up
the road I found a job here and it's
I've been here for what thirty seven
years something crazy like that Wow I
spent the first 31 years of my life I
was born right across the street from
you over at wright-patt and you know
it's fascinating that I've really been
into to stoicism for maybe the last
decade or so after reading many of the
Great's but I've got to tell you you you
I know you've written quite a few books
but the book I want to talk most about
today and I'll hold this up for the
camera for folks watching this on
YouTube is a guide to the good life and
the the the subtitle here is the ancient
art of stoic joy now the reason I like
this book in particular bill is I find a
lot of stoic writing to be very
informative but I also find to be
somewhat somewhat dry and your your
writing is not that in fact I find it to
be very lucid and very digestible and
also it's a great reference I actually
for folks who were watching this can see
I've got two bookmarks here I find that
I keep going back to this book and using
the index that you have in the book to
look up particular topics in fact I even
quoted from this book and in our next
book that's coming out called love
people use things now you've got a new
book as well called the stoic challenge
and can you maybe give a just a brief
overview on the difference between these
these two books
okay the guide was written back in 2008
it was sort of a sequel to a book on
human desire that I published in 2004 of
2006 and in that desire in that book on
desire I went into it thinking that I
wanted to become a Zen Buddhist and it's
an example of an academic twofer I could
get two for the price of one because I
could not only get a publication but I
could find out more about Zen Buddhism
and to be complete in the writing of the
book on desire I had to look into
alternative philosophies of life
stoicism was one of them and it very
quickly became apparent that stoicism
had all a lot lower entry cost then Zen
Buddhism did now I'm not putting down
the Zen Buddhists you know they good
people and and and they have a different
way of approaching it but it occurred to
me that given my personality giving my
temperament that stoicism would be an
easy fit so I decided to start
practicing it very quickly realized that
it worked
thought I need to share this with the
rest of the world at that time there
weren't a lot of books for general
audiences on stoicism now they're coming
out at about the rate of one a week if
you look on Amazon so it's a it's become
a crowded field and I don't claim to be
the pioneer there were some books most
of the books were written for an
academic audience but I thought
for the world they need to know about
this and then I subsequently
after that wrote a book on insults the
stoic approach to insults and then as if
I hadn't had enough yet I decided to
have a really simplified kind of
technique driven book and and that
became the stoic challenge and that's
how to deal with life setbacks and and
it's interesting how that's turned out
because we're in the middle of a setback
right now in the form of the kovat
nineteen pandemic and so that's created
some thinking about you know in my mind
about how stoicism can be useful in
these times now for the unfamiliar
people often hear the term stoicism and
we think of a stoic person a small a
stoic but there's a difference between a
small s stoic and a person who is a
stoic so maybe maybe talk a little bit
about what is stoicism and and that that
sort of misconception of a stoic person
yeah the big misconception in the one I
had before writing the book on desire is
that these Stoics are people who just
grimly take what life can throw at them
and then reading the actual Stoics I
found out how wrong that was that
they're people who enjoy delight and
they seek joy in life and they came up
with these strategies they they were the
preeminent psychologists of their time
they came up with these strategies for
avoiding the onset of negative emotions
and when those negative emotions appear
for overcoming them quickly or
preventing them from leading you astray
and those are very easy to use
techniques very effective techniques so
then the realization that they aren't
these grim individuals they're these
people do
their best to live lives full of joy and
that was a turnaround epiphany for me
and so I decided I was going to become a
practicing stoic right now people
listening to this thought though often
think in fact one question that we had
submitted from Keir was how his stoicism
related to minimalism and and what I
would say is minimalism has a lot more
to do with the the the at least
minimalism as a life style has a lot
more to do with the material possessions
in fact it starts with the material
possessions and realizing what is
essential stoicism I would say goes goes
beyond that while obviously taking into
account the material things that most
likely aren't going to make us happy but
also realizing some things in our life
can augment or enhance our experience of
life what did the Stoics have to say
about material wealth and material
possessions let me start out by by
saying that when I was in high school I
discovered Henry David Thoreau in red
Walden and it was a pivotal moment just
because I came to realize how pointless
the pursuit of you know achievements and
wealth that most people engage in is the
Stoics have a really interesting spin on
that so you can find a whole range of
people who had different connections
with them with materialism you have meu
Sonia's Rufus who lived a very simple
basic life and he he thought you know if
you live alone on an island and raise
your own food you're in great shape and
at the other end you find Seneca who was
up the first century AD equivalent of a
billionaire and he gave these apparently
very lavish parties and then the
question is how can that be how can
somebody who's living the life of a monk
like me sonjia's Rufus have something
some common core in common with Seneca
and here's one way to think of that
it's for Seneca you know what if life
presents you with something wonderful
savour it and while you savor it realize
that there's a very good chance in fact
it's for sure that someday it will no
longer to be available to you if nothing
else your own death will prevent you
from enjoying it anymore so if it's
there savour it don't long for it if it
goes away well you took advantage of it
while you while you had it so it's an
interesting psychological approach well
but I've got a bunch more questions for
you but this is tends to be a listener
driven show so I want to dive into some
of our our voicemail questions here our
first one is from Stalin in Lima Peru
Peru my question was if you think your
message is applicable to old cultures so
bill it sounds to me like what stalin is
is asking here he lives somewhere else
he's in Lima Peru and I often get this
question about minimalism but I think
the answer is probably going to be
similar with respect to stoicism as well
I know in your book you you talk about
how there are some people who are
predisposed for stoicism but what I and
I would argue the same thing with with
minimalism people who are predisposed to
maybe jettison the superfluous material
possessions to make room for what is
truly important in their life if that's
how we're defining minimalism here but
but what I would say is that just about
anyone can benefit from it doesn't mean
that they necessarily will or that it's
appropriate for them but if we're
talking about the deliberate use of the
resources we have I don't know who
wouldn't benefit from that and I would
think the same would be true for
stoicism yeah I agree with that because
if you look around the world you find
there are societies where people are
affluent the United States would be an
example of that where people some people
are happy some people are thriving some
people are miserable and you
places where people are impoverished in
you know financial terms and yet some
people are happy and some people are
miserable you look at the Stoics and I
mentioned me Sonia's Rufus before so he
was exiled to the island of G Aros in
the Aegean Sea and it was this desolate
Island and he got in trouble the Stoics
had a problem with that they tended to
get in trouble with the powers-that-be
and during this time on the island he
simply said well I'm now on an island
before I was not now I am so what am I
gonna do I'm gonna do the best with what
I've got where I am and succeeded in
having apparently a rewarding for him
existence people would come to visit him
and say well aren't you miserable here
and he'd say well no why should I be at
the other extreme you have Seneca and I
told you before he was a billionaire he
would practice poverty so one of the
things he would do is go for periods of
time depriving himself of the good
things in life just to keep you know in
balance just to know what it was like
and the interesting thing is if you have
a lot and it's taken away it can be a
very very depressing thing if you're
used to not having a lot there's a
chance when you can actually be more
alive because you're more appreciative
of the things that you do have so we
have these examples in history we have
these examples in geography what
determines your happiness in life is
your approach to life your material
conditions play a role but not the key
role yeah that's why I often say you
know there's nothing inherently wrong
with material possessions in fact you
know Ryan and I when we started the
minimalist we didn't set out to be to be
monks or ascetics
we certainly didn't set out to be people
who
from Spartan ISM where you can't stop
getting rid of things it we had reached
this condition that a lot of Westerners
had reached where we had too much stuff
and it was getting in the way of what
was important and I find that with
stoicism you start to question what is
important in your life and maybe realize
that oh man
I've been focusing on the wrong things
for so long that I don't even know what
the right things are to focus on yeah
the right things cannot be the
possession of physical things it's - and
you can look around for evidence I know
people who are relatively poor I know
people who are quite wealthy and it's
it's hard to see you know you there is
no direct correlation their life is what
you make of it and your values so why do
people acquire wealth one of the primary
reasons is they seek social status and
if they have lots of stuff they become
the object of admiration and that cuts
to different ways right because they can
be the obvious of the the object of
admiration but they can also be the
object of envy you know and people who
really hope something bad happens to
them because they don't deserve what
they've what they've got so what should
you be aiming at if not physical things
you should be aiming for a good life and
the Stoics this is one interesting case
where the Stoics agreed with a Zen
Buddhists so what's a good life it's one
where you have as few negative emotions
as you can
negative emotions include anger include
Envy include grief so you try that that
becomes your goal and it can be that
physical objects get in the way of your
attaining that goal you know if you go
around your days
wishing you only had more money so you
could have a better car you're gonna be
miserable
if on the other hand when you get into
your older car whatever and are driving
and then realize how much easier it is
to go places then if you had to walk
perfect you know in particular if it's a
snowy or rainy day it it's your mindset
that determines the effect that your
possessions have on you realize to that
even if you're a relatively poor
American you're living in the dream
world of your great great grandparents
you know if you said to them okay in my
pocket here I have this device this
small device that will allow me not only
to have a telephone conversation with
someone in Hong Kong but I can look at
their picture while I'm doing it
you know and again I've a verbal yeah
yeah and I have in my pocket in my cell
phone more computing power then existed
on the campus of the University of
Michigan when I set foot there in 1970
that is just a miracle and yet you know
you have your cell phone at first it's
amazing and then you take it for granted
and then it's a serious kind of
addiction after that so it's a kind of a
descent and you get your cell phone and
it's the thing of your dreams and then
they come out with a new model and then
you start saying gee I don't know you
know what will people think so a lot of
people go through life chasing a mirage
and a wise person will realize the folly
of that yeah I think it's it's
fascinating that often the object of our
satisfaction in the moment becomes the
object of our discontent the cellphone
is a great example of that because as
soon as you get it you get that dopamine
rush and and many other material
possessions are similar to this but of
course they break or they get old or
they're no longer useful to us and we
tend to cling to them
that will bring the the value that they
once brought to us but of course they
rarely do
Stalin I'm gonna send you a copy of a
guide to the good life I think you
really enjoy this book just so many
great thoughts here also expanding on
what Bill talked about with respect to
wealth and also status quite a bit in
the book about that our next question is
from Shanna in Tucson Arizona I'm 26 I'm
in my last year of grad school in
Arizona up until this point I've been
financially dependent on my parents who
live in Florida they bought all my stuff
and I'm not sure how to tell them
especially my mom about my minimalism
journey my mom's favorite hobby is
shopping and shall often mail me
unsolicited clothing or things or text
me photos of shoes when she's out
shopping or send me emails about sales
this can be extremely frustrating
especially after I told her I don't want
or need anything else how do i how do I
explain minimalism to her I'm scared of
being perceived as unappreciative for
everything they've done for me and I'm
scared to react negatively has that's
often her first reaction all right bill
so so for Shanna here it sounds to me
like this is a a problem with respect to
either values or beliefs which I like to
delineate both of those things and you
touched upon the word values earlier and
it sounds to me like maybe her mother
and she valued different things at this
point and there's a certain terror and I
even hear it in her voice
yeah I'm 26 I'm financially dependent on
my parents until very recently and I'm
afraid to tell them no I'm also afraid
to tell them these people that I love
about some changes I'm making in my own
life and I assume when when someone is
going down this Stoicism rabbit hole
it's intimidating especially when you
when you have to reveal this this this
sort of lifestyle change to other people
yeah it's a
it's a tough tough situation to be in
here's a thing I've discovered and that
is if you have different values than
other people some people will accept it
and say you know it's a it's a diverse
world and we have all sorts of different
opinions but other people will take it
personally they will assume that because
you don't share their values that you
disapprove of their values that you're
disapproving of them and that's where
things can get tricky so you know I'm a
parent myself so I kind of know the
tensions that are there and we do our
best to let our kids discover their own
values and so I I don't know if I have
any really great easy to advice but
think of it in terms of just a long-term
project your mother is attempting to
show that she loves you she's attempting
to give you things that make her happy
thinking that they'll make you happy as
well
so the intentions are great and for that
alone you know you should you should
love her you should honor her and then
the question is just kind of redirecting
kind of training and it's a long-term
project yeah but you know when she
offers you something you know it's a
that's wonderful thank you thank you for
the thought but you know I really can't
use it because I'm trying to simplify
I'm trying a different approach and I
wish you well because you know some
parents can pick up the clues other
parents just can't imagine that their
kids could turn out different than they
do you know what's fascinating to me in
a conversation like this I found one
thing that works really well instead of
telling your parents no finding out what
you should say yes to instead of saying
no no I don't want that or no don't give
me that gift this is especially a
contentious time with with Christmas
gifts or birthdays or holidays where
there's sort of the obligatory
gift-giving going on
and I find that instead of saying no
don't get me that find something you can
say yes to and that quite often is not a
material possession but there can still
be a a gift within their presence
whether it's sharing an experience with
them or or figuring out what you can do
together or maybe there is an actually
useful material possession that you
could that would add value to your life
and if so again nothing wrong with
owning material possessions it's having
the right ones in your life that don't
get in the way of living a meaningful
life and and so Shanna what I'm going to
say to you is that I totally understand
and that it is a difficult conversation
to have with your parents especially
when we're talking about conversations
around values and beliefs and and just
to put a pin on those two things yeah it
sounds to me like you and your mom
probably do actually have similar values
there's a good chance you do she cares
about you you just have different
beliefs around how she should be caring
about you right in her mind gift-giving
is a love language and we've been told
that we've been sort of sold this meme
in our society of gift-giving being a
love language and so she's trying to
express that love and in the way that
she knows how to express it however you
can as bill said sort of retrain her to
understand that there are other ways
that she can be loving towards you so
you you can help her understand what
your beliefs are and then help her honor
those at the same time appreciating the
fact that you two have different beliefs
and that's totally okay and if you can
accept it respect her different beliefs
that's one step closer toward her
accepting and respecting your beliefs
Shanna I'd love to sin to you I want to
see a copy of our book essential it's an
essay collection in there there's 12
different areas of intentional living
and there are a few that I think you'll
find particularly useful one there's a
chapter on gift-giving and there's also
a chapter in there about minimalism and
and our stuff and in dealing with our
stuff so if you like our podcast you'll
really like the audiobook version
essential that's a collection or if you
want the book book or the e-book happy
to send those to you as well oh and uh
you're in Tucson Arizona if you want to
make a quick road trip over we're going
on tour in we'd postpone dauer less
coast tour San Diego would be the
closest stop for you but Shawn if you
could reach out to Shanna and give her a
couple tickets to the LES Coast tour we
have an event in San Diego also seven
other cities along the west coast of the
United States and Canada for folks are
interested you can just find those
details on our website the minimalists
comm slash tour I do want to move on to
our lightning round this is where we
answer your text message you can text
your questions and comments to nine
three seven two oh two four six five
four those texts go straight to my phone
and straight to Ryan's phone I know that
sounds a little bit crazy but we answer
as many of the questions as we can that
people text us all the time
and we can't answer every question but
we do reply to a bunch of them plus we
answer some here on the podcast now bill
during the lightning round this is where
we typically try to answer questions
which is they a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so people can copy and share
our pit the answers on social media if
they like but don't worry bill we just
monitor on a little bit and we tweeze
out something that is pithy once we once
we get something worth worth tweeting
softer the challenge
well his thought has a question for us
he says how do you practice stoicism
without losing one of the foundational
things that make us human and that
foundational thing he says is emotion
and I think we kind of touched on this a
little bit belly people often conflate
being a stoic person with being a person
who is a stoic and those two things are
different but how do we become Stoics
without losing human emotion I would
regard myself as a quite an emotional
human being Wormley emotional human
being
so what I've done though is radically
diminish the number of negative emotions
I experienced I rarely if ever
experienced in anger I've gotten I'm not
perfect yet but I've gotten under much
greater control stoicism is not about
abolishing emotion it's about trying to
minimize the number of negative emotions
in embracing the positive emotions Wow
that is definitely tweetable I love it I
would say that my pithy answer is just
too much of a good thing is a bad thing
and and I find this with there's a good
example Paul bloom at Yale wrote a book
called I think it's called the case
against empathy have you have you heard
about this no I'm not familiar with that
okay well it's fascinating because we
often use this term empathy as a as a
good thing but he makes the argument
that it's actually a bad thing and what
we actually mean is compassion we don't
we don't want to have too much empathy
you think about your if you're gonna
have a surgery on your knee you don't
literally want your doctor to feel your
knee pain that's probably going to
prevent him from doing the the best job
possible and but of course you you want
him to have a certain amount of
compassion for you when in that
situation you don't want him to be
emotion less and I love the idea of
minimizing obviously and we can't
eliminate all negative emotions but we
can choose to let them go and don't you
think quite often though we tend to hold
on to them what why do we why do we
grasp so tightly to many of these
negative emotions there seems to almost
be a a comfort in feeling the feeling
the negativity
yeah well it's a social thing and you're
expected to do it in the Stoics said
that when disaster happens you're gonna
experience grief that's just part of
human nature but to extend that grief is
a waste of your time energy in life that
you need to be thinking the positive
signs you need to be thinking that
tomorrow is a new day and you move on
alright before we get into our added
value segment and our listener tips
today it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week what are
the potential pitfalls and draw
acts of Stoicism were the most coherent
criticisms of stoicism what's the
ultimate goal of stoicism and we're also
going to talk about how the Stoics would
have approached social media today we're
gonna talk about the kovat 19 crisis and
how the Stoics would have approached
that we're going to talk about embracing
stoicism with a family and we're going
to talk about the one thing that Stoics
do every single day plus I got a bunch
more questions for William B Irvine and
if you want to hear all that listen to
this week's maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast we're gonna
talk about so much this week you're
currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
and our guests we record an entirely
different much longer maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast it's just
two bucks and it's the most honest way
for this podcast to earn an income
because we don't believe in
advertisements because advertisements
suck so we make money only if you find
value in and support what we create by
the way when you subscribe to the
minimalist private podcast you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app find all the details at the
minimalists com slash support alright
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners g'day guys this
is Tristan from Ally in Germany I wanted
to share an efficient way to follow the
news without having to compulsively
check all the time or relying on some
social media algorithm so what I do is I
use RSS feeds for all the content I'm
interested in most websites that have
some sort of news feed allow you to copy
an RSS link into an RSS reader app when
you subscribe to an RSS feed or near
articles from the website will show up
in yarisis Reader when you open an
article in the reader it gets marked as
read you can filter out read articles so
once you've read something it will no
longer take home any space some websites
have a dedicated button from which you
can copy the RSS link into a reader
however with a lot of websites and don't
explicitly advertise their RSS feed you
can just copy the URL from your address
bar there's why you can for example
subscribe to youtube channels without
even having a
I account it also works with podcasts as
podcast links typically rely on the RSS
standard so you can really have all your
content in one place the reader that I
use is called feed bin it's an online
reader which syncs to all my devices
because thing about feed bin is you can
filter incoming articles by keywords and
automatically perform actions on them
for example I've subscribed to The
Economist's Asian feed but I'm really
just interested in news concerning
Australia not so much the rest of the
region
so I have feed bin mark any articles in
the Asia feed as read that don't contain
the word Australia these automations can
actually be much more complex allowing
you to save a heap of time feed bin is
five years dollars a month or 50 years
dollars a year there is a similar
alternative called inner reader which
also has a free version if you're new to
the whole thing I would recommend you
try out the free version or one of many
other free readers and see whether you
actually need any automation tools other
extra features you can then still switch
as it's very easy to export all your
feeds in a single file and import them
to another reader much like transferring
bookmarks when switching browsers hi my
name is Karen and calling from Hartford
here in the UK I'm calling with some
tips today for anyone who's been through
bereavement recently it's a tough thing
to go through and you still have to deal
with all the objects that are left
behind and that's been quite a difficult
process for me number one tip is
remembering that the love is not in the
object the love you have for that person
is not on the objects that's a thing
that I've heard before in the podcast
but it's been my little motto for
dealing with this my father passed away
in January and I've had a lot of objects
and things to go through his head so
I've just been saying that over and over
to myself and it's been very very
helpful
my love for him is in the things I did
for him when he was alive the times I
told him I loved him and in my memories
that I carry with me for the rest of my
life number two and this wouldn't be for
everyone is that I've chosen to make a
memory bear after some of these old
clothing you can just find online if you
google memory there there's lots of
different companies I've gone with one
in the UK called Lily's love that I
found on Facebook but not just for
bereaved people's clothing also they can
make wedding dresses bears out of
wedding dresses
there's outlaw Billy flaming
so if your children have grown up it's
another good thing that you could think
about doing with the clothes the first
thing is just remembering that the
greatest object my parents could
bequeath me is me my flesh my blood they
chose to raise me and that's an amazing
gift the gift of life and it's really
important that I hang on to that I've
been surprised baby so they didn't have
to have me but they carried on and I
know parents aren't always brilliant
they're going to always make the best
choices but they chose to try they chose
to try and raise me well and I know that
I only honor that gift if I spend the
time now looking after myself as I live
my life rather than stressing over some
old crockery or CDs though I hope those
texts help someone I'm sending out my
love to anyone who's going through the
same experience at the moment alright
y'all thanks again to William B Irvine
for joining us today
check out his books we'll put a link to
all of them in the show notes best one
to start with I believe is a guide to
the good life which I'm holding up here
for YouTube he also has to still work
challenge several other books we'll put
a link to his website in the show notes
and real quick four right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists as you can see
if you're watching this on YouTube I'm
in my living room right now but I've
been recording some Quarantine
conversations with a q QQ over on
patreon I mean pick up the phone each
day and just calling a different friend
or family member or loved one or friend
of the podcast as well dan Savage Dave
Ramsey Annika Harris former partner of
mine Colleen McCullough she's an artist
Feuer if you read everything that
remains you you read about her I've been
talking to a bunch of different people
in my life about how they're handling
and some of them are even thriving
during these these times during this
crisis and I want to talk to them about
their anxieties about their fears about
their stresses and also about ways that
they're they're dealing with everything
that's going on right now and I've been
really surprised by how many people are
doing really well at a time like this
and I wanted to figure out how that was
was possible and so we've been having
these conversations there about 12
minutes each some of them are maybe a
little bit longer than that but each day
I'm doing one of these conversations
over on patreon so if you're interested
in that
they're free by the way to anyone who is
a patreon supporter of ours thank you if
you are a patreon supporter it keeps
this podcast 100% advertisement free you
find all the details of our patreon.com
slash the minimalist also you can follow
the minimalists on social media we're on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram at the
minimalists if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists com you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails each week if you're
not on that email list you've missed
some really good simple Sunday emails
over the last few weeks I did one
recently called minimalism renewed it's
about a post coronavirus real really
post pandemic world and what to expect
out of our new normal and so wrote wrote
an essay about that and try to delineate
essential from non-essential and junk
and and talking about looking ahead
instead of looking backward and I think
you'll find some value in that so you
can sign up for our simple Sunday emails
they're totally free just go to the
minimalists com put your email address
at the top we'll never send you spam or
junk we just want to keep you informed
and we want to add value to your life
and we think we can add value to your
inbox with some simple writings and also
our podcast show notes there for our
added value this week you know I was
thinking about stoicism and Becks and I
on Easter we drove out to Palm Springs
which was a fascinating trip because it
was deserted obviously and we weren't
trying to be around people we were just
looking for some Sun it was actually
raining in LA and so we drove out east
to Palm Springs and it was beautiful and
sunny and the you know hiking areas etc
but also in town it was clearly it was
desolate but we were listening to a sort
of playlist I have going and there's a
song from the band called the album leaf
and the song is called window from their
album in a safe place when I think of
Stoicism for whatever reason this song
come
to mine first so I hope you enjoy window
by the album leaf and if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listen y'all we'll see you next time and
minimus